so hensler declares that the marriage
has become very unsupportable unless she
consents to having her mouth surgically
closed my god man
holy cow you put this in front of the
court a pleading is a document that you
file with the court and whenever i file
a pleading it is well researched it
makes good faith well-reasoned arguments
and it is spell-checked within an inch
of its life but the pleadings we're
talking about today
have none of those things these are the
most bizarre and ridiculous pleadings
that have ever been filed in an american
court we start with the iowa man who
requested
trial by combat so in america we take
pride in a judicial system that allows
anyone to have their grievances heard
before a neutral judge or a jury of
their peers and instead of resolving
disagreements through duels like the
days of yore legal disputes can be
addressed in a calm and civil manner
well that is the ideal at least
because reality is often
much much different enter david ostrom
of paula kansas who during a heated
custody battle against his ex-wife
requested in iowa court turned their
legal battle into a literal battle
complete with samurai swords in an
effort to resolve a dispute over his
ability to communicate with his two
children and get his ex-wife to pay
property taxes on their former home mr
ostrom filed a motion challenging his
former spouse and her attorney to quote
trial by combat mr ostrom was
purportedly inspired by richard luthman
a staten island attorney and game of
thrones aficionado who requested a trial
by combat to settle a dispute with
another lawyer and his clients in mr
ostrom's motion he wrote my ex-wife and
her attorney indicated they have
destroyed me legally now i wish to give
them the chance to meet me on the field
of battle where i will rend their souls
from their bodies
mr ostrom ever the chivalrous type said
his ex-wife's attorney would be allowed
to fight in her place as her quote
champion mr ostrom defended the legality
of this request before the court by
writing quote trial by combat was still
regarded as a legitimate method for
dispute resolution when the constitution
was ratified in the united states by the
original 13 colonies to this day trial
by combat has never explicitly been
banned or restricted as a right in these
united states check bait
never rescinded still okay that's how
the law works right
um
so mr ostrom also requested a
three-month delay so he could obtain two
samurai swords for the fight in
opposition to mr ostrom's medieval
motion the council for ostrom's ex-wife
who refers to himself in the response as
quote potential combatant very cheeky
that is a excellent defined term argued
quote although the respondent and
potential combatant do have souls to be
rendered they respectfully request the
court not order this done we humbly
request that the court deny this motion
as the potentially life-ending
ramifications surely outweigh the
severity of the petitioner's proposed
legal remedy of trying to avoid
responsibility for property taxes and to
acquire additional telephonic
communication
what a buzz kill seriously
now i regret to inform you that the
judge denied mr ostrom's motion while
granting opposing counsel's request to
temporarily suspend mr ostrom's child
visitation rights and order a
psychological evaluation like a guy
can't just request
trial by combat to the death i mean
judges
mr ostrom was declared sane and then
demanded his ex-wife and her attorney
also get sanity tests mr ostrom insisted
he was neither violent nor crazy and had
no intention of hurting anyone rather he
was simply frustrated with what he
believed was a system stacked against
men in custody disputes with financial
support and wanted to draw attention to
the issue now trial by combat is
technically illegal in almost every
state and in fact in kentucky of all
places there is an anti-trial by combat
law that says every elected official who
takes the oath of office must actually
swear before god that they never fought
in a duel with deadly weapons nor
challenged or aided any in such fight
now hashtag not legal advice regardless
of the legality of trial by combat it's
probably a bad idea to settle disputes
with deadly weapons especially if you
want to get elected in kentucky
or accepted a challenge to fight a duel
with deadly weapons
but that takes us to perhaps the most
bitter divorced filing of all time and
as you just saw emotions can run high in
matters of the heart that's why for
divorces it's often a good idea to hire
an attorney to proceed with an air of
professionalism
or you could just choose the path of
texas attorney paul frank hensler who
handled his own divorce with a
handwritten petition that was um
well it was interesting let's just uh
take a look at this now fair warning
this is a 1985 divorce petition from
texas so don't be surprised from what
follows where it's not exactly the most
evolved of pleadings and in what reads
like a badly written country song or
honestly an awesome country song hensler
states his wife moved out of the house
after only 10 months of holy matrimony
after she
got pissed off and hauled ass with their
car the mastercard her 365 dollars in
cash her federal civil rights
nine-year-old employment discrimination
case against the texas department of
human resources to which she is welcome
having bored me stiff for two years
about just how everybody picks on her
um so hensler declares that the marriage
has become very unsupportable due to a
conflict of personalities between he and
his wife but says the real blame lies
with his ex-wife failure to provide the
quote legitimate ends of the marriage
that prevents any reasonable expectation
of reconciliation unless she consents to
having her mouth surgically closed my
god man
holy cow you put this in front of the
court
now hensler attests that he and his wife
have no children together although quote
petitioners swears on oath he did
everything he could to knock her up
um
that's not even germaine to the pleading
here but hensler sarcastically says his
wife is quote liberated now and
feminists don't have children by male
chauvinist pig lawyers so she swears
gosh i i can't believe this marriage
only lasted 10 months now hensler
requests the court divide their estate
among parties based on possession
clarifying he means the legal sense of
possession not possession like in horror
movies
but hensler does assert his wife could
easily stand in for quote the girl from
the exorcist i'm the holy spirit
hensler requests the court grant his
divorce and have his wife's name legally
changed to the demonic bella abzage jr a
play on the name beelzebub hensler then
closes the petition with quote screw you
while signing the pleading with
respectfully submitted paul f hensler
fun fact lawyers who signed things
respectfully nine times out of ten were
secretly meaning no respect intended
except me of course always with due
respect
not all lawyers but that brings us to
the defense attorney who demanded that
everyone call him captain justice now to
promote the fair administration of
justice courts serve as evidentiary
gatekeepers to ensure only reliable and
authenticated evidence is admitted at
trial while excluding any evidence that
needlessly inflames confuses or
prejudices the trier of fact but in one
tennessee burglary case the dueling
efforts of prosecutors and defense
counsel to obtain a fair trial took a
very bizarre
and let's call it a humorous turn now
back in 2013 the state of tennessee was
scheduled to prosecute donald powell for
aggravated burglary assistant district
attorney general tammy reddig was the
local prosecutor who represented the
state while powell was represented by an
appropriately named drew justice before
trial ada redig filed a motion in
lemonade to get the court to exclude
evidence she believed would unfairly
prejudice the state's case her request
stop defense counsel from referring to
the state's legal representative as the
government because that's not very nice
yes that's right the prosecutor who
represented the government of tennessee
demanded that the defense counsel be
prohibited from calling her the
government because it might bias the
jury against
let me see here
the government
now in ada redig's one-page motion she
suggested mr justice's repeated
references to the state's attorney as
the government was derogatory and
prejudicial to the state's case and mr
justice should instead refer to the
state's attorneys by their names or
titles mr justice responded to this
baffling motion with his own
appropriately cheeky response the
government has moved to ban the word
government mr justice begins noting that
the state of tennessee quote offers
precisely zero legal authority for this
rather nitpicky position mr justice
argues granting such a motion would
violate his first amendment rights mr
justice asserts that the term the
government is not inherently derogatory
particularly since courts frequently
referred to the prosecutor's office as
the government in the alternative mr
justice argues that if the ada gets to
choose her own name then we the defense
should get to choose our own names as
well mr justice first requested the
court stop referring to the defendant as
defendant stating that the word has a
negative connotation that quote
dehumanizes mr donald powell mr justice
instead proposed calling his defendant
by his full name mr donald powell quote
the citizen accused or that innocent man
but mr justice was not yet finished he
asked the court that he no longer be
referred to by the meager name of lawyer
or attorney that's when drew justice
went full ted mosby pleased to meet you
captain i'm galactic president superstar
mcawesomeville first mr justice
suggested that the court call him
defender of the innocent
as all defendants are presumed innocent
until proven guilty he then proposed the
title of guardian of the realm mr
justice also suggested if ada redig gets
to be quote assistant district attorney
general the defense counsel deserves an
appropriate military title to match
captain justice mr justice sorry uh
captain justice argued that the court
shouldn't even be calling him the
defense writing the quote whole idea of
being defensive comes across to most
people as suspicious the captain then
proposed that his side instead be dubbed
the resistance and as a star wars fan i
can certainly see the appeal of that
last one but the cheeky defense counsel
closed his motion with a similarly wry
fashion quote wherefore captain justice
guardian of the realm and leader of the
resistance primarily asked the court
deny the state's motion as lacking legal
basis alternatively the citizen accused
moves for an order eliminate modifying
the speech code as aforementioned and
requiring all other euphemisms and
feel-good terms as the court finds
appropriate
now you might have thought that lawyers
are incapable of committing extensive
trolling in court but this motion shows
just how wrong you are
yeah sometimes if the prosecution does
ridiculous things you gotta just troll
the crap out of them now sadly the court
denied the assistant district attorney
general's motion while also denying
defense counsel's request to be called
captain justice tennessee's fears that
being called the government would
prejudice their case turned out to be
unfounded after waving his right to a
jury trial mr powell was in fact
convicted of attempted aggravated
burglary and his conviction was upheld
on appeal but it seems like mr justice's
suggestion that his client be called
that innocent man
was just a little bit premature if not
incredibly petty trolling so a plus on
that but that takes us to an actual
meritorious motion because one of the
best reasons if not the best reason to
ask for a continuance
is that the chiefs made it to the super
bowl man now of the many skills that
lawyers possess one we certainly lack is
the ability to see the future but one
possible exception is dui attorney and
kansas city chief superfan denise kirby
who successfully predicted in a legal
filing that the chiefs would break a
50-year championship drought that would
render her too busy cheering on her team
at super bowl 54 to attend trial here's
how it went down now in october 2019
miss kirby filed a motion to continue
her february 3rd 2020 dui trial on the
grounds that she'd personally be in
miami watching her team play in super
bowl 54. at the time of the motion the
concept was laughable so much so that
apparently everyone in the courtroom
laughed at her request but then the
chiefs made it to the super bowl so ms
kirby filed a new motion to continue
trial according to miss kirby's motion
the courtroom erupted in laughter when
she confidently asserted in october that
she would be in miami to watch the
chiefs in the super bowl she further
noted that the court had advised that
should that happen it would grant the
continuance quote it happened wrote miss
kirby as a result miss kirby would not
be back in time for trial and thus
needed a continuance the motion ends
with quote go chiefs because of course
it does now ultimately the chiefs and
miss kirby would have the last laugh in
a historic fourth quarter comeback the
chiefs overcame a 10-point deficit with
21 unanswered points to beat the san
francisco 49ers 31-20 it was
heartbreaking
i was born in san francisco i'm a big
49ers fan
sorry the court having granted miss
kirby's continuance helped fulfill the
prophecy that allowed her to see that
historic victory and that takes us to
the importance of being earnest
hemingway now lawyers have a reputation
for being humorless buttoned-up suits
well i'm a professional i'm serious and
i'm a professional
can't imagine why but we lawyer types
love to cut loose and have some fun so
what is an attorney to do when our
extracurricular activities clash with
trial dates well if your florida lawyer
frank lauterbach
getting ready to attend an ernest
hemingway look-alike contest you hope
that your court is understanding of your
scheduling conflict and uh
non-refundable deposits as well uh the
court was not here's what happened in
2012 florida man jerry allen betorff was
facing federal charges in connection
with a murder-for-hire plot involving
the murder victim's wife christy seahorn
betorff whom jerry had met at a swingers
club and who later became jerry's wife
just your typical florida love story now
frank louderback was scheduled to go to
trial in july of 2012 but everything
changed for the saint petersburg lawyer
when he became a semi-finalist in the
annual ernest hemingway look-alike
competition at sloppy joe's bar in key
west now louderback understandably felt
this fortuitous change in circumstances
merited a brief suspension of trial
informing the court quote undersigned
counsel has secured a block of six rooms
to accommodate family friends and fans
and has had to pay non-refundable
deposits now non-refundable deposits
notwithstanding u.s district court judge
stephen d maraday denied the request
writing quote between a murder-for-hire
trial and an annual look-alike contest
shirley hemingway a preferred admirer of
quote grace under pressure
would choose the trial and in his denial
judge meredith showcased his own sense
of humor and admiration for hemingway
citing dorothy parker's 1929 new yorker
profiled the author quote at his most
robust hemingway exemplified the
intrepid defense lawyer he works like
hell and through it he has the most
profound bravery he has had pain and the
kind of poverty that you don't believe
he has had about eight times the normal
allotment of responsibilities and he is
never once compromised he has never
turned off on an easier path than the
one he staked himself it takes courage
judgment closes the emotion by citing
the iconic final line of hemingway's the
sun also rises and you've gotta love the
way that the judge ends this order best
of luck to counsel in next year's
contest the motion docket 127 is denied
and while louderback would live to
compete another day
sadly battorff and his wife pleaded
guilty to the charges and were sentenced
to life in prison and in perhaps the
greatest miscarriage of justice
would never live to see a hemingway
look-alike contest of course none of
these lawyers pleadings make any sense
they are completely illogical they could
really use a logic or math course from
brilliant today's sponsor brilliant is
an online learning platform for stem
that replaces lecture videos with
hands-on interactive lessons brilliant
is for curious learners both young and
old professional and inexperienced one
of my favorite courses is all about
logic brilliance logic courses covers
liar and truth teller riddles logical
fallacies machine logic and even some
strategic game theory logic is of course
a crucial skill that lawyers need every
day not the ones that we covered in this
video but
at least lawyers generally speaking
nonetheless and brilliant lets you learn
by doing rather than listening to hours
of boring lectures learning through
doing is scientifically proven to be the
most effective way to master any skill
the courses have storytelling
interactive challenges and problems to
solve within brilliance library you'll
find courses and topics like calculus
linear algebra and math that applies to
trading and finance you'll also find
courses on gravitational physics
astronomy and machine learning and you
can level up in just five minutes a day
by working on the daily challenge each
daily challenge provides you with the
context and framework that you need so
you don't have to take a deep dive if
you don't want to you can sign up and
start learning for free today at
brilliant.org legaleagle or you can
click on the link that's on screen right
now or in the description the first 200
people to sign up will also get 20 off
their annual subscription plus clicking
on that link really helps out this
channel or click on this link over here
with all of my other legal videos so
click on screen or i'll see you in court